so as you have a great line in the film
that has to do with sort of idealism the
young Nicole taurine sure yeah this is a
good spot you added this put that line
in I cut too okay you know Oh
paraphrases but anyways it's a guy who
says I don't know if I'll ever stop
wondering about girls who pass by you
know the ones you see for only like a
couple of seconds walking down the
street sending a car around light but
with the phones in a cafe and it's for
those couple of seconds that your eyes
beg you to let them steal more of her
Iman does this way better but that's
that's the line I guess your friend too
and you wrote that line yeah tell us
where does that come from that's really
interesting i resonated with that line
uh-huh you know it's one of those things
you know you write this this movie
autobiographical I said the only the
part where the guy sneezes why he pees
and sprays all over ABBA magazine Sabac
autobiographical but this line you know
it has to do with the core character of
this film which is played by Iman Varney
his self-proclaimed sailor who left one
Shore has in which the other most of
time those people and I'll you know they
don't want to drop an anchor especially
they haven't reached what they intend to
get and if something comes along that
they feel it could be like dropping
anchor like a girlfriend you're not sure
about getting pregnant whatever baby you
know this re-examining their entire take
on everything and you know Varney's you
know all these things that kind of pass
by you that's you paddled the film along
the roadside it's kind of like all these
things that we pass by on our way to get
where we intend
to get and you know he has to do it's
one of the one of the one of the ideas
in the film do you think that describes
a lot of artists and a lot of people in
LA and it maybe is almost necessary for
great art they're never satisfied with
where they are and they have to kind of
keep going and keep searching mm-hmm
yeah that's uh you know LA and I've been
here for eight years now and I'm
discovering the city like you know
peeling an onion really I'm there's so
many parts of the city I go to it I'm
still tourists like for the first time
I'm steppin my foot and like oh wow look
at this it's just a large city my
country has less people in the city you
know and they're all the same this is
like I'm fascinated with all the
differences here one of my things is
celebrate the difference I'm really big
on that and I believe in it and if
there's anything this movie does is
trying to get that point across and
where our female protagonist colorblind
she's seen all the shades of grey
and that's the only thing that she sees
but it's really a way to say she sees
things differently and it's she
celebrates the difference and but
talking about LA that's what I love
about it that's I love the old all the
mishmash of everything you know but as
far as our people in LA constantly I
don't know you know I don't know I think
it's um you know they're you know it's
it's more of a global issue
and going back to man woman whatever is
flawed how much how many flaws did you
want to put in the characters of your
scripts and how important was that oh
yeah they're all nuts like everybody in
the script there's you know Daryl for
the for the couch
you know like a silver linings playbook
yes somebody compared it with that I was
like thank you
somebody compared this film with wim
wenders movies and how we saw to to my
shame so it's it's weird that people
compare with my winders but you know you
know flaws it's one of those things I
think you know with time and age we're
making progress you know this fields and
but there's some little it is then we
cannot scratch you know as and it's you
know that's things that I'm always
interested in obviously the uncensored
bits of our over of ourselves so
audience likes to watch audiences like
to watch flawed almost crazy people is
that because we can't accept what's in
ourselves so we can point fingers and
it's funny watch you know I always
wanted to make films they would do to
other people what other films have done
to me it's a I'm vengeful little person
now I can't but you know there are
moments in the you know watch a film and
it does something to you and somebody
said every film changes your life and
you'll receive an idea it stretches your
brain and a brain never goes back to the
size it was before you idiot stretched
it now there are other films that shrink
too pretty but we're not going to talk
about manic but you know I do believe
that you know
you know kind of confronting certain
issues head-on is important and you know
all the ideas would pick up along the
way two films two conversations two
books two anything really like whatever
life's life throws at us
it creates us so and a lot of it is you
know just kind of processing a lot of
that there was a coat came up with kick
King stumbled on the Woody Allen book
and said Gordon Willis said that and he
said you're by who you are and I
thought that was a pretty good way to
put it
you